- [Instructor] We've talked about things
that might drive inequality,
things that Thomas Piketty
refers to as forces of divergence,
but I always think about or at least what
some of what he cites is
forces of convergence,
so forces of convergence
or things that might make
the world a more equal place,
and the primary one that he cites
is one that's very close to my heart,
and this is the spread of knowledge.
Spread of knowledge.
And what we have here
is a couple of charts
that show the spread of knowledge
at least on a macro basis,
on a regional basis,
and show how it has been a driver
of starting to equalize global output.
As we start in 1700, we see that,
it's going from 1700 through
the Industrial Revolution,
frankly as the West was
developing or industrializing,
the West, Europe and America,
became a larger and larger
percentage of global output,
and Asia became a smaller
and smaller percentage.
But then as you go into the
second half of the 20th century
and into the 21st century,
you see the dynamic change.
Asia's percentage of world output
is increasing more and more,
and that's arguably happening
because you've had a
transfer of knowledge,
a diffusion of knowledge from the West
to the East from modern
manufacturing techniques
and design techniques and
engineering techniques
and whatever else, and that's
why as we are in the beginning
of the 21st century Asia is turning into
a major industrial powerhouse.
They've learned from the
West and in some dimensions
are even improving on some of
the knowledge from the West
to make themselves more
and more productive.
So at least on a regional basis,
this shows that the world
is becoming more equal
because of this spread of knowledge.
And we could also see it
on a per capita basis,
so this right over here,
they're essentially plotting over time
per capita GDP as a
percentage of world average,
so the world average right over here
is obviously 100% of the world average,
so that's why it's just
a flat line at 100%.
And we see as we go through
the Industrial Revolution,
Europe and America, essentially the West,
the West, its per capita GDP
becomes a larger and larger percentage
of the average per
capita GDP for the globe,
but that was true until recently,
until the last few decades.
The last few decades as a
percentage, it's gone down.
Now that doesn't mean that
per capita GDP is going down.
It just means that its share
as a percentage of world
average is going down,
and that's really because
Asia's per capita GDP
has been growing even faster
because of, once again,
that spread of knowledge.
So at least this idea
of spread of knowledge,
it does seem to be playing
out at a regional level.
It's bringing, at least right now,
it seems like Asia's participating
much more than Africa,
but it's starting to bring the non-West,
the East, more in line with the West
in terms of protective capacity
and wealth per person and per capita GDP,
however you want to look at it.
Now an interesting question,
that's at a regional level.
What about an individual level?
And we'll talk about that
more in the next video.